let me start with the most weighted
point on our agenda the package of Risk
Reduction measures in the banking
industry I'm very happy to report it
after dozens of sleepless nights by the
members of the presidency team many
meetings and discussions we finally
reached an agreement among member states
we believe this is success because the
package of four files is one of the
stepping stones - about completing the
banking union the proposals agreed today
seek to implement the reforms agreed at
international level following the
financial crisis these measures will
ensure that any outstanding challenges
of financial stability are correctly
addressed let me congratulate the
Bulgarian presidency on the general
approach reached on the 2016 banking
package this package is a key
deliverable in risk reduction in the
banking sector it aims to complete the
post crisis regulatory agenda and
address outstanding issues for financial
stability and introduce internationally
agreed standards in EU legislation as
regards our anti tax avoidance gender so
we welcome that today ministers gave the
final green light on --use new tax
transparency rules for tax
intermediaries these rules will come
into force in 2020 and will provide more
transparency on the role of
intermediaries who sell products and tax
structures that can potentially help
clients to avoid tax